s went to something called a breath work
Journey it's an event it was hosted by a
dude named Vitali martyo he claims that
most illnesses are caused by unprocessed
energy which is right up you know s's
alley he got he was really excited about
this he went to this thing where um he
was going to release unprocessed energy
through intense breathing techniques and
the all the people who go scream and cry
and sometimes even vomit did you throw
up
no I did not I did not throw up I did
hear a lot of people throwing up it it's
it's a definitely like whoa you know
like you're trying to concentrate in
breathing and then you're looking for
your spirit eyes and all a sudden you
somebody just vomiting behind you it's
not so great in the only if the only way
for me to be spiritually connected is
through vomiting repeatedly I don't want
it I don't want to be spiritually
connected I don't did the place smell
like vomit
Wolfie yeah I mean mid mid session the
smell in there got pretty intense
everyone was vomiting sweating like I
remember at one point Howard I was
breathing and trying to concentrate and
I just got this whift of like hot dogs
from somebody vomiting it was just
wasn't
great wow W that spell whiffed whiffed I
got a
Whi K Y U Robin that's how you spell it
Wolfie said he saw tears streaming down
people's faces and one woman had to be
ushered out of the room cuz she was
vomiting so intensely right Wolfie yeah
they pulled her out of there so quickly
her hand went up and and like it was
like a SWAT team swarmed order to pull
her out she she had a complete and you
never saw her again she just disappeared
I let's be clear this means it's going
well right I mean things are
going I would have stopped the seminar
right
now yeah this would not be a signed that
if it was
working Robin I think we better give
people their money
back we're making them
sick you know s is so impressionable he
gets looped into the hysterics and
starts screaming too because he's s and
you know he doesn't want to miss out s
wants to be special also so here's he's
got to be a super performer as well
right s's going to show them how to
really get in
[Applause]
[Music]
touch there he goes
idiot I love this guy seriously Wolfie
it's it was just weird right like seeing
s now laying on the floor blindfolded
screaming right I mean it's just weird
and you work with I mean he was just
opening up so much I I I couldn't
believe everything that was pouring out
of him it was it
was anyway the experience gave s an
overwhelming sense of gratitude for his
loved ones especially his mom he started
carrying
on Mom thank you so much for me being
the most wonderful beautiful loving
person in my world I'm so grateful for
you Mom for everything you had to go
through what a weirdo what is that voice
are you are you crying is that what's
going on like it's like weird that voice
oh yeah tear tears are streaming down my
face yeah I was lying down and lying
down yeah and my face was completely wet
he was wearing a sleeping mask and I
could see tears coming out the side of
the
Mask I love you if you if I was in a
room with you I hug you right now man oh
I love you too how
yeah you need a big hug pal I would stay
away from him under every circumstance
when I when I come over Howard for
dinner we can
hug